Filipino side we got me and dietrix
heyy you kid me for real that was so
Filipino get demonetized or remonetized
I think right now the more gayer you are
the lifted we
becomes and you got matching shirts come
on Commit F's going to do
it we kiss Paton this is like Kiss Me
dude I have the power you didn't even
kiss me stop deflecting honestly dude
it's like you're actually gay watch this
I'm I'm super gay on the lips though on
the lips I was trying to kiss him on the
lips were you yeah but you didn't want
to kiss him on the lips I didn't know
that I thought you trying to kiss me on
the cheek if you're comfortable with
your sexuality you should kiss me don't
I don't like being
challenged didn't do it he didn't even
do it he did movie Magic he did movie
Magic where with the nose movie Magic
like this oh my God oh my God it's just
little basos between
boys B with the boys you some B